[Musique]
bon vous semble plus aller sportive 1 2
3 qu'est ce que vous pensez et
transports en commun parisiens alors de
façon très global extrêmement élevé au
niveau tarifaire par rapport au service
rendu
parce que plein de dysfonctionnements et
votre sale en pense quoi
ma soeur je pense qu'elles sont bas et
mais complètement les steaks
non mais c'est vrai parce que vraiment
les transports après c'est vrai c'est
vraiment juste quand j'ai dansé avec les
stars le soir que voilà c'est randy des
deux bouchers donc j'évite avait sinon
je te prends assez rarement quoi ça va
dgo ouais j'aime bien ouais après le
reste on belle j'ai crevé je veux un
carton mais archi cartonne avec les sa
bouille à fond les ballons sacs ou là
par contre un peu trop c'est un peu web
mais ça des gorges ont fait pas très
propre c'est quand tu rentres dans l'est
dans les wagons à chaque fois ces crabes
ça dépend des stations mais des fois ça
pue maintenant c'est sûr que
c'est un peu galère parce que
souvent tu prends tout le monde vu que
moi je les prends super tôt le matin ou
tard le soir c'est galère bonjour ouais
c'est bon bah c'est pour le transport en
commun parisiens pour celui de touche ou
encore les transports en commun mon pote
chez du bifff moi c'est ton frère
mais on n'est pas sûr d'arriver à
l'heure et sert à votre elle en pense
quoi
très habile en pense quoi e.on frère en
et frère abbas et le bonnet la fois je
suis un peu rebelle quoi les cristaux et
moi je retiens la clé usb sans demander
l'autorisation
j'ai l'impression est un peu tombé
[Applaudissements]